évidemment je suis pas d'accord et c'est
pas parce que c'est m6 ou parce que
c'est karine le marchand et parce que
j'aime bien le principe de quelqu'un qui
vient ça si c'est moi mélenchon qui
parlait de sa surdité
c'est un des rares moments où il m'a ému
et je trouvais que quand ils sont
intéressants l'émission devient
t'intéresse alors ça allait bien marcher
politique 3 millions sans me après ça
s'était effondré avec les meilleurs car
si pour elle en revanche ça n'intéresse
pas willis en catastrophe quatre
responsables m'intéresse au complet
concédé politique je vais pas vrai que
les gens je suis assez d'accord at on vu
je suis d'accord avec isabelle sur un
truc c'est que sur les politiques ça
marche pas mal ça intéresserait suspendu
et c'est vrai que les animateurs les
chanteurs qui était passé ça c'était des
carcassonnais se savoir que kev adams m
la tomate mozza ou pas moi j'ai envie de
la farce est un pote bombe commis
quelque part logique on n'arrête pas
d'embauché aux politiques d'être dans
leur tour d'ivoire d'être déconnectés de
la vie quotidienne quand ils sortent de
leur tour première se livrer sur leur
vie quotidienne sur leurs ressentiments
encore si on est là c'est de leur tour
et la rue ton patron du rugby décolle
pas
pas dans la demie les hommes politiques
au lieu de faire au cinéma à leur tour
d'ivoire sont à tony moore eva va te
faire un vote 60 photos peuple passe
dans son dos et toi t'es où vas en train
de boire un pastis vous êtes toujours
désagréable qui est nouveau bookmaker
rené s'est parlé pendant les vacances
j'ai acheté un cadeau j'ai rencontré
j'ai trouvé cela a marché un truc pour
lui un jeu plus du moyen âge qui n'ont
jamais ils vont jamais sur le terrain
dit soit tu fais de la politique au bar
en train de boire un pastis eut refait
le monde on barre mais qu'il te rends
compte que tu as tout vous venez de vous
dire ça on m'a dit non à dire aux
québécois
voilà l avez vous dit arrivé si tu me
suivait à mars r&b tu recoba et ben tu
démontres donc 6 et 9 du département
génie urbain foutu mls tenir les mets tu
débarques tu dis bon c'est vrai pas
beaucoup d'argent si tu devais me paie à
boire au bar à marseille j'y vais des
patrons 4 quelques mois je suis papa il
ya quelques g20 tenu le bar tu me
connais le wild
[Applaudissements]
dumas nul qui leur a dit romeo bas le 10
le samedi mathieu et je te rapproches
pas la route et du stade
écoute moi
vingt sept à l'extérieur de une fois par
semaine on tue un peu je suis que tu
vois plus comme en est le danger les
trois nuits avant qu'est ce qu'il est ce
qu'on peut recommander une tournée de
pointe